dr jane goodall welcome
well thank you and i think you know we
we
couldn't have a complete interview
unless people know mr h
is with me because everybody knows miss
stage
hello mr h um in your ted talk
17 years ago you warned us about the
dangers
of humans crowding out the natural world
is there any sense in which you you feel
that the current pandemic
is kind of nature striking back it's
very very clear
that these zoonotic diseases
like the corona and
hiv aids and all sorts of other diseases
that we catch from animals
that's partly to do with destruction of
the environment which
as animals lose habitat they get crowded
together and sometimes
that means that a virus from a reservoir
species where it's lived harmlessly for
maybe hundreds of years jumps into a new
species
then you also get animals being pushed
into closer contact with humans
and sometimes one of these animals
that's just called
you know it provides the opportunity for
virus to jump into people
and create a new disease like copic 19
and in addition to that we are so
disrespecting animals we hunt them
we kill them we eat them we traffic
them we send them off to the
wildlife and with the wild animal
markets
in asia where they're in terrible
cramped conditions in tiny cages with
people being contaminated with blood and
urine and feces
ideal conditions for a virus to spill
from an animal to an animal
or an animal to a person i'd love to
just dip
backwards in time for a bit because your
story is so extraordinary i mean despite
the arguably even more sexist
attitudes of the 1960s somehow
you were able to break through and
become one of the world's
leading scientists discovering this
astonishing series of facts about
chimpanzees such as their tool use and
so much more
what was it about you do you think that
allowed you to make
such a breakthrough well the thing is i
was born loving animals
and the most important thing was i had a
very supportive mother
didn't get mad when she found earthworms
in my veg just so they
could be in the garden and she didn't
get mad when i disappeared for four
hours and she called the police i was
sitting in a henhouse
because nobody would tell me where the
hole was where the egg came out
i had no dream of being a scientist
because women didn't do that sort of
thing
in fact there weren't any men doing it
back then either
and everybody loved to mix their mum who
said if you really want this you're
going to have to work awfully hard
take advantage of every opportunity if
you don't give up maybe you find a way
and somehow you were able to kind of
earned the trust of chimpanzees in the
way that um
no one else had what looking back like
what were the most
exciting moments that you discovered and
what is it that people still don't get
about chimpanzees well the thing is you
say
see things nobody else had get their
trust like no but nobody else had tried
quite honestly so basically
i used the same tech techniques that i
had
to study the animals around my home when
i was a child
just sitting patiently not trying to get
too close too quickly
but that it was it was awful because the
money was only for six months i mean
you can imagine how difficult to get
money for a young girl with no degree
to go and do something as bizarre as
sitting in a forest
and you know finally we got money for
six months so an american
philanthropist and i knew with time i
get the chimps trust but did i have time
and weeks became months and then finally
after about four months
one chimpanzee began to lose his fear
and it was he
that on one occasion i saw i still
wasn't really close but i had my
binoculars
and i saw him using and making tools to
fish for termites
and although i wasn't terribly surprised
because i
read about things captive chimps could
do
but i knew that science believed that
humans and only humans used and made
tools
and i knew how excited leaking would be
and it was that observation that enabled
him to go to the national geographic
and they said okay we'll continue to
support the research
and they sent yuka van lauer a
photographer filmmaker
to record what i was seeing so
a lot of scientists didn't want to
believe the tool using
in fact one of them said i must have
taught the chimps
since i couldn't hear them it would have
been a miracle but anyway
once they saw hugo's film and then that
with all my descriptions of their
behavior
um the scientists had to start changing
their minds
and since then numerous other
discoveries um that
place chimpanzees much closer to humans
than people care to believe i think i
saw you say one point that they have a
sense of humor
how how have you seen that expressed
well
um you see it when they're playing games
and there's a bigger one playing with a
little one
and he's trailing a vine around a tree
and every time the little one's about to
catch it
uh the bigger one pulls it away and the
little one starts crying
and the big one starts laughing you know
and then jane you observed
um something much more troubling um
which was
these instances of chimpanzee gangs
tribes groups um being brutally violent
to each other i'm curious
how how you process that and
whether it made it made you kind of i
don't know depressed about about us
we're close to them did it make you feel
that violence
is irredeemably part of part of all the
great apes somehow well
it obviously is and my first encounter
with
human what i call evil was the end of
the war
and the pictures from the holocaust and
you know that really that really shocked
me that that changed who i was i was 10
i think
at the time and when when the
chimpanzees
when i realized they have this dark
brutal side
i thought they were like us but nicer
and then i realized they're even
more like us than i had thought and
at that time in the early 70s
it was very strange aggression there was
a big thing about is
aggression innate or learned
and it became political and
it was i don't know it was a very
strange time and i was coming out saying
no i think aggression is definitely part
of
our inherited repertoire of behaviors
and other side i asked a very respected
scientist
what he really thought because he was
coming out on the clean slate
aggression is learned and he said jane
i'd rather not talk about what i really
think
that was a big shock as far as science
was concerned for me
i was brought up to believe a world of
all things bright and beautiful
you know numerous beautiful films of
butterflies
and bees and flowers and you know
nature is this gorgeous landscape and
many many
environmentalists often seem to take the
stance
yes nature is pure nature is is
beautiful humans are bad
but then you have the kind of
observations that you see when you
actually look at any part of nature in
more detail you see things to be
terrified by honestly what do you make
of nature how do you think of it how
should we think of it nature is
you know i mean you think of the whole
spectrum of evolution
and there's something about going to a
pristine place
and africa was very pristine when i was
when i was young
and there were animals everywhere and
i never liked the fact that lions killed
they have to i mean that's that's what
they do they
if they didn't kill animals they would
die
and the big difference between them and
us i think
is that they do what they do because
that's what they have to do and we can
plan to do things our plans are very
different
we can plan to cut down a whole forest
because we want to sell the timber or
because we want to build another
shopping mall or something like that
so our destruction of nature and our
warfare
we're capable of evil because we can sit
comfortably
and plan the torture of somebody far
away that's evil
chimpanzees have a sort of primitive war
and they can be very aggressive but it's
of the moment
it's how they feel it's response to an
emotion
so your observation of the
sophistication of chimpanzees
doesn't go as far as as what some people
would want to say is the sort of the
human superpower
of being able to really
simulate the future in our minds in
great detail and plan
make long-term plans and
act you know to encourage each other to
achieve those
long-term plans that that feels even to
someone who's spent so much time in
chimpanzees that feels like a
fundamentally different skill set that
we just have to take responsibility for
and use much more
wisely than we do yes and i i personally
think
i mean there's a lot of discussion about
this but i think it's the fact that we
developed
the way of communication that you and i
are using
and because we have words i mean animal
communication is way more sophisticated
than we used to think and chimpanzees
gorillas orangutans
can learn you know human sign language
of the deaf
but we we sort of grow up
speaking whatever language it is so i
can tell you about things
that you've never heard of and a
chimpanzee couldn't do that
and we can teach our children about
things
abstract things and chimpanzees couldn't
do that so
yes chimpanzees can do all sorts of
clever things
and so can elephants and so can crows
and so can octopuses
but we design rockets that go off to
another planet and little robots taking
photographs
and we've designed this extraordinary
way of
you and me talking in our different
parts of the world
when i was young when i grew up there
was no tv there were no cell phones
there was no computers
it was such a different world i had a
pencil pen
a notebook that was it so just going
back to this question
about about nature because i i think
about this a lot and i i
i struggle with this honestly um
so much of your work so much of so many
people who i respect
is about this passion for trying not to
screw up the natural world
so is it is it possible is it healthy is
it essential perhaps to simultaneously
accept that many aspects of nature are
terrifying but also i don't know that
it's
awesome and that some of the awesomeness
comes from its potential to be
terrifying and that it is also just
breathtakingly
beautiful and that we cannot we cannot
be
ourselves because we're part of nature
we cannot be whole
unless we somehow it embrace it and
a part of it help me with the language
jade on how we should
how that relationship should be well i
think one of the problems is you know as
we developed our
intellect and we became better and
better
at modifying the environment for our own
use and
creating fields and growing crops where
it used to be forest
or woodland and you know of course well
we won't go into that now but
we have this ability to change nature
and as we've
moved more into towns and cities
and relied more on technology
we've many people feel so divorced from
the natural world
and there's hundreds thousands of
children growing up in inner cities
where there basically isn't any nature
which is why this movement now to green
our cities
is so important and you know they've
done
experiments i think it was in chicago
i'm not quite sure
and there were various empty lots
in the very violent part of town
so in some of those areas they made it
green they put
trees and flowers and things shrubs in
these vacant lots
and the crime rate went right down
so then of course they put trees in the
other half
so it just shows and also have been
studies done
showing that children really need green
nature for good psychological
development
so we we are as you say part of nature
and we disrespect it as we are
and that is so terrible for our children
and their children's children because
we rely on nature a clean air clean
water
for regulating climate and rainfall
look what we've done look at the climate
crisis that's
us we did that so a little over 30 years
ago you made this
shift from scientists mainly to
activists mainly i guess
why conference in 1986
scientific one i got my phd by then and
it was to
find out how chimp behavior differed if
it did from one environment to another
there were six study sites across africa
so we thought let's bring these
these scientists together and explore
this
which was fascinating but we also had a
session on conservation
and a session on conditions in some
captive situations like
medical research and those two sessions
were so shocking to me i went to the
conference as a scientist
and i left as an activist i didn't make
the decision something
happened inside me so you spent the last
34 years sort of tirelessly campaigning
for a better relationship between
people and nature um what
what should that relationship look like
well we you know it's again you come up
with
all these problems people have to have
space to live
but i think the problem is that we
we've become in the affluent societies
too greedy
i mean who needs honestly who needs four
houses
with huge grounds and why do we need yet
another shopping mall
and so on and so on so we are
looking at short-term economic benefit
money has become a sort of god to
worship as we lose all spiritual
connection with the natural world
and so we're looking for short-term
monetary
gain or power rather than
the health of the planet and the future
of our children
we don't need to care about that anymore
i'll never stop fighting i mean in your
work
um specifically on chimpanzee
conservation you've
um you've made it practice to put
people at the center of that local
people to engage them
how has that worked and do you think
that's an essential idea
if we're to succeed in protecting the
planet
you know after that famous conference i
thought well i must learn more about why
chimps are vanishing in africa and
what's happening to the forest
so i've got a bit of money together and
went out and visited
six range countries and learned a lot
about the
problems faced by chimps you know
hunting for bushmeat and the
live animal trade and caught in snares
and
human populations growing and needing
more land for their crops and their
cattle and their
villages but i was also learning
about the plate faced by so many people
the absolute poverty the lack of health
and education
the degradation of the land and
it came to a head when i flew over the
tiny gombi national park
it had been part of this equatorial
forest belt right across africa
to the west coast and in 1990 it was
just this little island of foresters
tiny national park
all around the hills were bare and
that's when it hit me
if we don't do something to help the
people find ways of living without
destroying their environment
we can't even try to save the chimps so
the jane goodall institute began this
program take care we call it takari
and it's our method of community-based
conservation it's
totally holistic and we've now
put the tools of conservation into the
hand of the villagers
because most tanzanian wild chimps are
not in
protected areas they're just in the
village forest preserves
and so they now go and measure the
health of their forest
they've understood now that protecting
the forest isn't just for wildlife it's
their own
future that they need the forest and
they're very proud
the volunteers go to workshops they
learn how to use smartphones
they learn how to upload into platform
on the clouds
and so it's all transparent and they've
the trees have come back
there's no bear hills anymore
they agreed to make a buffer zone around
gambi
so the chimps have more forests than
they did in 1990
and they're opening up corridors for us
to link the scattered
chimp group so that you don't get too
much inbreeding
so yes it's worked and it's in six other
countries now
same thing i mean you've been this
extraordinary
tireless voice all around the world just
traveling so much
speaking everywhere inspiring people
everywhere how
on earth do you find the
the energy you know the fire to to do
that because
that that is exhausting to do every
meeting with lots of people it is it is
just physically exhausting and yet here
you are still
still doing it how how are you doing
this jane
well i suppose you know i i'm not
obstinate i
i don't like giving up i'm not going to
let
these ceos of big companies who are
destroying the forest or the
politicians who are unraveling all the
all the protections that were put in
place by previous presidents and you
know who i'm talking about
um and you know so i'll go on fighting i
care about i'm passionate about
the the wildlife i'm passionate about
the natural world i love forests it
hurts me
to see them damaged and i care
passionately about children
and we're stealing their future and i'm
not going to give up
so i guess i'm blessed with good genes
that's a gift and the other gift which i
discovered i had
was communication whether it's writing
or speaking
and so you know if if going around like
this wasn't working
but when you every time i do a lecture
people come up and say
well i had given up but you've you've
inspired me i promise to do my bit
and we have our youth program roots and
shoots now in 65
countries and growing fars all ages
all choosing project help people animals
environment
rolling up their sleeves and taking
action and you know they
look at you with shining eyes wanting to
tell dr j
what they've been doing to make the
world a better place how can i let them
down i mean as you look at
the planet's future what worries you
most actually what what scares you
most about where we're at
well the fact that you know we have a
small window of
time i believe when we can start at
least start healing some of the harm
and slowing down climate change
but it is closing and we've seen what
happens
with the down around the world because
of kogit 19
clear skies over cities some people
breathing
clean air that they've never breathed
before and looking up at the shining
skies at night
which they've never seen properly before
and
you know so what worries me both
most is how to get enough people
people understand that they're not
taking action how to get enough people
to take action national geographic just
launched this
extraordinary film um about you uh
highlighting your work over
what six decades um it's titled
jane goodall the hope so what is the
hope
jane well the hope you know my greatest
hope is all these young people i mean in
china
people will come up and say well of
course i care about the environment i
was in roots and shoots in primary
school
and you know we have roots and shoots us
hanging on to the values
and so they're so enthusiastic once they
know the problems and they're empowered
to take action they're clearing the
streams they're removing invasive
species
humanely uh that and they have so many
ideas
and then there's you know this this
extraordinary intellect of ours
we're beginning to use it to come up
with technology
that really will help us to live in
greater harmony and in our individual
lives think of
you know let's think about the
consequences of what we do each day
what do we buy where did it come from
how was it made
did it harm the environment was it cruel
to animals is it cheap because of child
slave labor
make ethical choices which you can't do
if you're living in poverty by the way
and then finally this indomitable spirit
the people who tackle what seems
impossible
and won't give up can't give up when you
have those but you know there are things
that i can't
fight i i can't fight corruption
um i can't fight military regimes and
dictators
but so i can only do what i can do and
if we all do
the bits that we can do surely that
makes a hole that eventually will
win out so last question jane i mean if
there was one
idea one thought one seed you could
plant in the minds of
everyone watching this what would that
be
you know just remember that every day
you live
you make an impact on the planet you
can't help making an impact
and at least unless you're living in
extreme poverty
you have a choice as to what sort of
impact you make even in poverty you have
a choice but
when we are when we're more affluent we
have a greater choice
and if we all make ethical choices then
we start
moving towards a world that will be not
quite so
desperate to leave to our great
grandchildren
that's that's i think something
for everybody because a lot of people
understand what's happening but they
feel helpless and hopeless and what can
they do so they do nothing and they
become apathetic
and that is a huge danger apathy
dr jane goodall wow i really want to
thank you
for your extraordinary life for all that
you've done
and for spending this time with us now
thank you
oh thank you
you